السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
ا الله اكبر
الله
اكبر لا
لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
الحمد
لله ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فلا مضل له ومن
يدلله فلا هادي له واشهد ان اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله صفي بخلق وحبيبه بلغ الرساله
وادى الامانه ونصح الامه وكشف الله تعالى
به غمه وجاهد في الله حق جهاده حتى اتاه
اليقين اما بعد فقال جل وعلا بتنزيله بعد
ق اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله حق تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
ثم اما بعد ان اصدق الكتاب كتاب الله
تعالى وخير هدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم وسلم وشرور محدثها وكل محدثه بدعه
وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله في النار رب
اشرحلي صدري ويسرلي امري واحلل عقده من
لساني يفقه قولي اللهم لا سحل الا ما ا
جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن اذا شئت سحلا
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
الله ربنا وقتنا ورجاؤنا ومولانا فنعم
المولى ونعم النصير
[Silence]
اللهى مح صلى الله عليه وسلم
اللهه
اللهانه
week
darkness all knowing
alles الحمد
الحد الله سبحانه وتالى gl he
bels we ask
him take a hold of ours and gu us
‏asing
there
there come back finance
‏person and the world and tribulation
and and going through all these things
but from my personal experience talking
to folks and even even with own life
seen
end
aalam ands to people
seen so much so that a lot of people
‏ises
andam
strs has brought upon
us and as
such it is okay to question
them and try what
iss us and how he us
toate a lot of times the tribulations
and trials that are introduced in our
lives happen
اللهه
[Silence]
‏stronger
signs
signes رحمه الله
سبهالى come
[Silence]
‏flow الله
سبهالى الله سبحانه
وتالى البقره
‏about
15 من الخو والجوع من الاو والثم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى الذين اذا اصابتهم مصيبه قالوا انا
لله وان اليه راجعون
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى قران واستعينوا بالصبر
والصلاه
[Silence]
‏trient
event human is in a that we
for eventually those
things a w in the
‏let
goed الله
سال
beke ان لله وان اليه
راجون الله سبحانه وتالى الله
سبحانه incl
الله سحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏we are in
position in he
think he saw that soul was perfect for
that job we have a job to do whether we
choose to do it
not as he bles
us because we are and because heit for
bl to in life
‏what people next اك عليهم صوات من ربهم
ورحمه واك
[Silence]
الله ائك عليه صوات من
رب الله سبحانه
وتالى واولئك المتدون
[Silence]
‏easy
عليه
what الله سبحانه
وت الله
‏we
bu
proper
and he
has a
dream
hasch
has and kids
house and
[Silence]
الحمد
upon not
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏are
الله سبحانه
وتالى human
nature
have
asked
why you ask me
‏ask
ask
الله الله سبحانه وتالى رب اني مثني وان
‏he says oh my
lord
adversity has
touched
means of
hand it's that gentle touch walks over
just gentle
touch
what has been taken from
him and he saying
اني
مثني you are the
mer
caning
that that
‏tri
tribulation
come
them and as we
today ex for us to us
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى الط سيجعل الله بعد
عر الله
[Silence]
‏tri you
know as famous qu
goes if someone pray
fores الله
سانتال ores them opp to
be if someone pray for
[Silence]
‏and that's the ence of what brs bring
الله سبحانه
وتالى فانما
العصر الله سبحانه
النساء كفا
بال asp of
my have to understand one
thing this life that we go through on a
daily
bas we might to be 80 years old 60 years
70 years old 50 years whatever allah
decreed for us to be
alive and we might have hardship and
tribulations we might go through this
roller coaster of the life ‏as as think
you
made
come more and
and
life
make come
[Silence]
قر لبث قال لبثنا يعي
‏that con time limit to me
and 24
cycle
earth
even and
all hour
‏apparently
2الى ائك عليهم صوات هم واولئك هم
المتد اللهانه وتالى
‏first tri tests us and tries us to
hardships and trials and if he does
chooses to test test us and try us then
he brings us victorious those and trials
and that he provides
us provides us to be steadfast in that
tribulation and trials then he equips
[Silence]
قران اقولوا ما تسمعون استغفر الله لي
ولكم وئ المس
زم فاستغفر انه غف
[Silence]
الرحيم الحمد
لله الحمد لله الواحد الاحد الفرض الصمد
الذي لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
عن سهيب قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عجبا لامر المؤمن ان امره كله خير
وليس ذلك لاحد الا المؤمن ان اصابت راء
شكر فكان خير له وان اصابته راء صبر فكان
خير له اوما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام مسلم صح رضي الله عنه
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عج امر
المؤ
alles there
is
aff الله سبهالى
الله سبحانه
وتالى ق وه
‏nothing happens to us
except as such if he has brought us to
to it he
us the differ the difference is how we
choose to deal with it in
our how we choose
to ى
[Silence]
‏and make us
those to
اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافينا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا وصرف عنا شر ما قيت انك تقضي
ولا يقضى عليك ولا يذل من واليت ولا يع من
عاديت تبارك ربنا وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا
اخوال سبقنا بالايمان ولا تجعل في قلوبنا
غ الذين امنوا ربنا ان رؤوف الرحيم اللهم
اغفرلي ولوالدي والمسلمين والمسلمات
والمؤمنين والمؤمنات والمسلمين والمسلمات
الاياه
الاموات ان الله قد امركم امرا بدا في
نفسه وسلم على قدسه وسى بكم معشرا ممس قال
عز قائما عليما ان الله وملائكته يصلون
على النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلم تسليما اللهم سلم وبارك و وعلى ابدك
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين عباد الله ان
الله يامركم بالعدل والاحسان وات ذي
القربى وينحاش منغي يعزكم لعلكم تذكرون
اذكروا الله العظيم يذكركم وزد لكم وذكر
والله اكبر وقوموا الى صلاتكم يرحمكم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
[Silence]
الله استو
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين اذا زلزلت الارض
زلزالها واخرجت الارض
اثقالها وقال
الانسان ما
لها يومئذ
تحدث
اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى
لها
يومئذ يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا
اعمالهم فمن يعمل مثقال
ذره
خيرا
يرى ومن يعمل مثقال ذره
شر
يره الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
[Silence]
والعاديات
ضبحا فالموريات
قدحا فالمغيرات
صبحا فاثرن به نكعا فوسطن به
جمعا ان
الانسان لربه
لكنود وانه على ذك
لشهيد
وانه لحب الخير
لشديد افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في
القبور وحصل ما في
الصدور ان ربهم بهم يومئذ
لخبير الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام علكم رحمه
الله السلام علكم رحمه
[Silence]
الله an
‏don ‏can mulle
me and
any any other
me what you
need you
pleas
لام ‏y